hey hey  [Music]  I'm not going not now  not ever why didn't you say this to me  when I was alive my husband died we  never got a note  [Music]  hey it's Hannah Hannah Baker I wish it  settle in because about to tell you the  story of my life more specifically why  my wife ended and if you're listening to  this tape you're one of the reasons why  and we're truth  don't believe everything you hear  whatever handout soft she saw she lied  about it on this page but she's a crazy  drama queen who just killed herself for  attention and had some Christmases bacon  human he creates our children  maybe I'll never know why you did what  you did I can with youngest and how it  felt you don't know the whole story what  else do I need to know you're just like  the rest of them but I'm not everyone is  just so nice until they drive you to  kill yourself and sooner or later the  truth will come out  [Music]  you